[Musique]
vous terminez l'année avec un spa quoi
j'ai une comédie musicale
une sorte de critique du showbiz
québécois dont vous faites partie
oui c'est quoi le dit mais là je peux
penser avant la sortie du jeu on parle
tellement que je connais ont peut-être
que c'était une mauvaise idée finalement
vous l'avez vu vous oui mais vous avez
pas eu l'impression de me mettre la main
sur le poêle parce que le statut du trio
l'icf met la main sur l'épaule quand
même depuis le début de ma carrière j'ai
jamais eu non plus peur de dire des
choses c'est sûr que les gens ils
écoutaient - parce qu'il était un peu
concentré sur le fait qu'à une voix
aiguë bien physique et des filles qui
travaillent chez nar cité mais mais j'ai
tout un drame ainsi le feu si j'ai tout
le temps dit les choses que je pensais
et j'ai du temps suivi mes valeurs donc
je pense que ma main sur le feu depuis
le début puis c'est de ce qu'est le
j'espère qu'à ne pas être au brûlis
[Musique]
j'étais sale et mal équipés ça sent le
purin mais vous n'y allez pas avec le
dos de la cuillère parce que vous
critiquez dans cette comédie musicale à
saint-hyacinthe là où ça sent la bouse
de vache mais gic c'est ce que j'aime
gilles meillet donc des choses moins fun
j'ai cassé le funk avec moi c'est une
odeur que j'aime
honnêtement j'ai grandi là dedans et
j'arrive l'adorent la boule que je
chante partout tellement j'aime seul
j'arrive à saint-hyacinthe le pij est
excité de sentir moi c'est quelque chose
de positif c'est mon enfance oui j'ai
que ça pue mais je veux dire j'ai une
sensation que j'ai grandi là bas puis
honnêtement c'est sûr que je retourne en
terre sainte
on se doutait on sait que sa pub je
devais est-ce que non mais c'est juste
que les gens qui marchent tout temps sur
des jeux il faut pour bien vous pourriez
dire de mal et je pense que les gens qui
disent on peut plus rien et tu le sais
quoi qui va t'arriver que jean-charles
c'est tout ce que ça m'a jamais fait
peur de faire fuir les gens
et cette fois pourtant ces réseaux
sociaux il ya des gens qui vous ravir il
ya des gens qui meurent à manses mais
c'est leur droit en même temps c'est mon
droit de com continue et facile pour la
laine et je me lance
qu'est ce qui vous déplaît qu'est ce qui
vous plaît dans le showbiz québécois ce
qui me déplaît c'est le scellement sont
je pense que c'est que les gens ils sont
peu conséquent c'est ils vont ils vont
être fâché quand gilbert rozon vraiment
fâché alors que quand ces publics
alors qu'avant mais je le bats ça ne
dérangeait pas d'avoir des contres avec
lui de le voir mais sont au courant mais
une fois que ça soit au jeu je savais
pas cessé je pense que le fait que ce
qui a fait que aussi c'est un milieu
quand même vraiment est centré sur
lui-même ccc vraiment et si je te flatte
d'une flotte alors ceci souvent ça me
manque parce que je comme et j'ai le
goût de travailler avec vous parce que
je vous aime vraiment cette époque parce
que je veux avoir d'autres contrôles
mais des risques à ça je pense à la
sphère julien lacroix ou l'été dernier
vous avez plus position ça aurait pu
vous coûter cher
julien lacroix est un ami aussi ce que
fait un calcul ou voulu y aller avec le
cas j'y vais avec le car malheureusement
ou heureusement ça dépend si j'aurais pu
vraiment tout perdre j'ai eu des
messages méchants mais un en général les
messages est assez positif puis je pense
que ça leur ait révélé un peu plus de ma
personne aux gens alors c'est ça qu'est
que c'est un risque mais en même temps
je pense que mon restaurant était de
paul fin je m'en serais voulu c'est si
ce n'était pas arrivé c'est ça je m'en
serais voulu d'avoir laissé des amis
aller tout seul au front je n'en ai
voulu aussi de continuer à travailler
avec des gens que j'estime et dangereux
même qui m'a même avant l'occident en
donne deux siècles de gourdon plainte du
petit lait manger donc ici un email
embauche quand les mâles tout votre
imaginaire la comédie musicale votre
spectacle
enfin roy tourne autour juste
de l'enfant ça semble encore vous
habitez et enfants vous êtes encore très
proches je sais pas à quel jeu est
encore en symbiose
oui vraiment on est très très très très
proches mes parents y habitent savais
que si je pouvais simon et jeanne boulay
en tout cas mes beaux parents aussi etc
c'est juste que moi je trouve ça
tellement intéressant aussi d'être des
proches des gens de générations
différentes qui mes parents la saison
les plus gentils puis douaumont était
maintenant je fais quelque chose et puis
je pense que je t'ai pas bonne je pense
que les gens m'aiment pas je pense que
ma voix face caen dans le rang 10
mettez vos ali il m'encourage tellement
que thé hyènes peu tout ce que je fais
ce serait un mensonge je sais pas
nécessairement mon public cible mais ils
voient que c'est créatif qui voit que
c'est ces nouveautés originales
c'est ce que les tiens quand rosalie
vaillancourt on vous souhaite pas de
bêtises pour 2021 merci beaucoup mais ça
me fait plaisir
[Musique]